robinson's entitled to go straight up  there which he did that was textbook and  so that's that's why that was not called  a foul  hornier missing that three robinson's  got another rebound  rhymes just hit the biggest shot of the  night  he was one of three  but an offensive rebound kicked back out  and now the knicks are up eight give him  credit they got guys that are willing to  take it and make it  [Music]  now you see him now you don't oh he  snapped julius randle's ankle bones  yo  that was like jordan against the knicks  [Applause]  two and a half left  clay shot clock at one randall step back  jumper airball 24-second violation  and we gotta watch steph against randall  watch this he thinks like he's going  back to the middle fake spin though oh  snapped his ankle bones  that is wild  he was so gone minute 40 here you  thinking threes  you're down six